[Música]
récords de temperaturas máximas
registradas olas de calor incendios
forestales definitivamente el hemisferio
norte vive uno de los veranos más
intensos de los últimos años que trae
consecuencias muy graves para nosotros
el planeta se calienta y el clima se
vuelve cada vez más extremo debido a la
huella que está dejando el hombre en el
planeta tierra un poco más de contexto
lo vemos en el siguiente reportaje que
ha preparado la redacción de France 24
veamos
son imágenes del estado de Texas en
Estados Unidos en llamas las intensas
olas de calor en el hemisferio norte
también golpean a Estados Unidos en
somer belt los incendios han consumido
16 casas y más de 2.000 hectáreas de
bosque los bomberos Siguen trabajando
para contener el fuego en otras ciudades
como Nueva York Philadelphia y Boston
hay alerta por el calor extremo las
temperaturas alcanzaron los 32 grados
celsius y en los próximos días el
termómetro podría llegar hasta los 37
grados la situación continúa empeorando
el sistema climático se le puede
comparar con un transatlántico gigante y
la dificultad para hacerlo girar
ralentizarlo y darle la vuelta es una
buena analogía en Europa la situación es
crítica desde el comienzo del verano
mientras que en España los bomberos
siguen luchando contra las llamas en
Zaragoza y Castilla y león el presidente
Pedro Sánchez dijo que más de 500
españoles murieron durante 10 días de
temperaturas extremas y en las vecinas
Portugal y Francia los incendios tampoco
dan tregua en Grecia se han necesitado
500 bomberos y unidades del ejército
para evitar que las llamas causaran más
daños en pentel y palini antosa y
geracas donde viven cerca de 90.000
personas a la lista de países europeos
afectados por el fuego se suman Albania
Y eslovenia
tenemos múltiples incendios en muchos
países desde Portugal hasta España en
Francia Italia Croacia iglesia y también
en eslovenia esto significa una gran
carga para los servicios públicos y es
por eso que la Unión Europea está
recibiendo gritos de ayuda
el problema es que debido a que estos
incendios están apareciendo en toda
Europa el sistema de ayuda de la Unión
Europea está sobrecarcados
el bosque de versan en Albania se redujo
a cenizas en Mirna eslovenia 200
personas fueron evacuadas de sus casas
debido al humo hasta el momento no se
registran muertos en Albania y eslovenia
los valores han sido verdaderamente
altos por ejemplo el Reino Unido tuvo
que decretar por primera vez en su
historia la alerta Roja de dado las
altas temperaturas que alcanzaron los 40
grados centígrados en un país que no
está preparado para este tipo de climas
en Portugal y España ya lo veíamos los
termómetros llevaron a superar los 46
grados y en Francia Por poco llegan a
los 50 grados los patrones del clima
Pues digamos que es normal que sucedan
dentro de los patrones estándares que
haya olas de calor Lo que sí es
irregular es la frecuencia la duración y
la intensidad que están teniendo esas
olas de calor en este momento por
ejemplo Europa Allí están viviendo el
promedio de temperaturas registrado más
alto en los últimos 100 años según lo
indica la convención marco de la ONU
sobre el cambio climático
pero esta ola de calor los incendios
forestales y la actividad Industrial
causan efectos en la contaminación
atmosférica porque según lo explica la
organización meteorológica La ola de
Calor hace a la vez de una especie de
etapa que captura y retiene los
contaminantes en la atmósfera provocando
entonces la formación muy cercana de la
superficie de ozono así lo vemos en este
mapa de Europa entonces hay una mayor
concentración de ozono en el oeste y en
el sur del continente pero hay que decir
que cuando el ozono está tan cerca de la
superficie no ayuda a protegerse a por
ejemplo a nosotros de El sol y eso pues
también ayuda a la contaminación nos
tenemos entonces que acostumbrar a estas
horas de calor intenso Cómo se verá
modificada nuestra cotidianidad con
estas condiciones extremas Qué planes
avanzan en las diferentes ciudades y
países para adecuarse a estas temporadas
de climas extremos y Qué consecuencias
traerá para la existencia de la
humanidad estas megas sequías el
deshielo la deforestación otros
fenómenos que se están acelerando con el
cambio climático qué tan comprometidos
estamos Entonces como sociedad para
hacer frente a este cambio que ya
prácticamente es inevitable pues lo
vamos a analizar en esta edición del
debate de France 24 para conversar sobre
este tema saludamos a Verónica Arias
ella es directora ejecutiva de la
coalición de ciudades capitales de las
Américas frente al cambio climático ella
está en la ciudad de Quito en Ecuador y
se une esta conversación desde la ciudad
de Miami en Estados Unidos Mauricio
Rodas él es ex alcalde de la ciudad de
Quito la capital ecuatoriana coordinador
de ciudades líderes en la acción contra
el calor extremo del centro de
resiliencia arch rockefeller les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar sus
preguntas y comentarios en las redes
sociales estamos en Twitter en Instagram
y en Facebook en donde no se encuentran
como arroba
france24_s@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta les recuerdo es
numeral el debate f24 en YouTube también
pueden nuestra señal en streaming y
puedo también
contarles que estamos ya en diferentes
plataformas en podcast todo el contenido
del debate lo pueden encontrar en
diferentes plataformas que ven ustedes
en pantalla en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
Bueno pues le doy la bienvenida entonces
a nuestros invitados comienzo con el
cerebro Mauricio
que nos atiende desde la ciudad de Miami
Punto de partida Mauricio bienvenido
Gracias por estar con nosotros en el
programa Punto de partida para este
programa para conocer opiniones de los
invitados lo que ha significado estas
olas de calor recientes en Estados
Unidos y en Europa y también esas
intensas Nevadas que se han presentado
en el sur del continente sobre todo en
la zona de la Cordillera entre Argentina
y chile vemos los dos extremos en los
dos hemisferios climas extremos en ambas
partes del mundo Cuál es su evaluación
de este cambio que se está generando con
estas olas de calor
Santiago Muy buenas tardes Muchas
gracias por la invitación un saludo
especial y un gusto compartir este
espacio con Verónica
efectivamente estamos viendo un cambio
notorio en las temperaturas producto de
lo que ya todos sabemos el cambio
climático que está afectando al mundo y
que se ha convertido de hecho en la
principal amenaza para la humanidad lo
que estamos presenciando ahora es un
efecto clarísimo del cambio climático Y
lamentablemente es algo que se irá
agravando más y más con el pasar de los
daños a medida que dichas consecuencias
del cambio climático se vayan agravando
lo que estamos presenciando actualmente
en el hemisferio norte en Europa en los
Estados Unidos es terrible pero es una
tendencia que ya se veía venir desde
hace varios años en Europa entre 1985 y
2020 se calculan aproximadamente más de
90.000 personas fallecidas como
resultado defectos el calor extremo aquí
en Norteamérica se calcula más o menos
que 20.000 personas al año pierden la
vida por efectos del calor extremo y el
problema es que además se estima que
estas cifras son subestimadas porque
muchas muertes se registran para otras
causas por causas por ejemplo cardíacas
o problemas renales o de otro tipo sin
embargo las mismas pudieron tener como
causa original precisamente los efectos
del calor extremo Así que probablemente
estamos hablando de que las hijas son
muchísimo más altas y de hecho hay que
entender Santiago que el calor extremo
es el fenómeno derivado del cambio
climático que mayor número de gente mata
en el mundo es decir si es que sumamos a
las víctimas de Los huracanes de los
tifones de las inundaciones de los
incendios forestales tenemos que todo
aquello en conjunto representa una cifra
menor
de las víctimas que cobra el calor
extremo para ponerle un ejemplo solo
aquí en Estados Unidos en el año 2020 el
calor extremo mató 20 veces más personas
que los huracanes claro el problema es
que mucha gente desconoces por qué
porque el calor extremo es un asesino
silencioso que mata gente de manera poco
visible En comparación con otros
fenómenos como huracán o como una
inundación claro ahora le doy el paso a
Verónica en la ciudad de Quito en
Ecuador bienvenida a Verónica Gracias
por estar con nosotros en el programa
punto de partidas opinión su balance de
lo que significan estas olas de calor
que estamos viendo en Estados Unidos y
en Europa y también esas Nevadas
intensas que estamos viendo en el
hemisferio sur en donde vale la pena
aclarar es invierno
Así es Gracias Santiago Gracias eh
Mauricio por compartir este este panel
definitivamente el cambio climático vino
para
eso lo estamos avisando desde hace
décadas cuando desde 1880 vemos desde
que se tiene Registro un incremento
sustancial cada década en términos de
temperatura el planeta se ha calentado
ya más de un grado y se emisora que esto
viene en aumento más de 1.5 o hasta dos
grados digo que se vino para quedar
porque eso no va a haber un retroceso
más bien este más de 2.500 científicos
para la conferencia de las partes que se
llevó a cabo en Glasgow del año pasado
han mencionado que viene en aumento y
que lamentablemente las metas del
acuerdo de París Simplemente no se han
logrado
cumplir Entonces estamos frente a una
declaratoria de emergencia dicho por el
secretario de Naciones Unidas y creo que
no lo estamos entendiendo no ha habido
un llamado de atención en este sentido
durante el año anterior de declarar
emergencias climáticas en varias
ciudades solamente Bogotá y Santiago lo
han hecho del hemisferio de acá de Las
Américas Y es importantísimo que tomemos
en cuenta todo esto porque fíjate esta
emergencia climática que ya estamos
viendo con los defectos
que está viviendo en Europa Simplemente
hay una pérdida de biodiversidad enorme
además de todas las vidas que se ha
mencionado anteriormente pérdida de
servicios ambientales pérdida enorme de
de agua entonces sí y simplemente esto
Esto es intangible esto no se puede Ni
siquiera calcular y esto viene en
aumento viene en aumento no es retroceso
lo dice verónicas de la ciudad de Quito
Mauricio ya lo vemos esto prácticamente
es imparable es un hecho estas olas de
calor van a comenzar a hacer más
frecuentes Cómo debemos prepararnos para
convivir con este tipo de fenómenos así
como en algunas zonas tropicales se
acostumbraron a los tifones o se
acostumbraron a los huracanes o a la
temporada de lluvias ahora cómo debemos
acostumbrarnos a tener con mayor
frecuencia este tipo de olas de calor
sobre todo en los extremos en el
hemisferio norte en el hemisferio sur no
sé qué tanto puede afectar a los países
que estamos ubicados en la zona más
cercana al Ecuador como Ecuador como
Colombia en cierta forma Perú Venezuela
bueno Primero que nada entendiendo que
este es un fenómeno que puede golpear a
cualquier zona del mundo y lo que está
ocurriendo en Europa ahora lo demuestra
por primera vez el termómetro en
Inglaterra por ejemplo supera los 40
grados centígrados y el problema es que
Inglaterra y otros países europeos no
estaban preparados para enfrentar un
fenómeno de este tipo doy un ejemplo en
Inglaterra o en Francia apenas un 5% de
las viviendas tienen aire acondicionado
mientras que Estados Unidos que sí ha
estado acostumbrado a enfrentar este
fenómeno por mucho tiempo más el 90% de
las viviendas tienen aire acondicionado
Entonces yo creo que la primera elección
es entender que este fenómeno puede
golpear a cualquier parte del mundo
incluso aquellas que jamás pensaron que
iban a sufrir de esto por un lado por
otro lado hay que entender que es un
fenómeno que se tiene que enfrentar
particularmente en las ciudades porque
recordemos que las ciudades sufren el
efecto de la isla urbana calor es decir
las ciudades son más calientes que la
periferia o que el campo Por qué Porque
el pavimento genera calor tenemos las
emisiones de los vehículos de los
propios aires acondicionados las zonas
urbanas evidentemente tienen menos
vegetación que aquellas en el campo y
eso hace que la temperatura se eleve
pero también son las ciudades en donde
se pueden aplicar múltiples soluciones
de innovadoras para enfrentar el
problema y proteger a la población
permita Como por ejemplo nosotros en el
centro de resiliencia
en el centro de resiliencia haz lo que
fue la que a través de la iniciativa de
ciudades líderes para el combate Al
Calor extremo hemos impulsado el
desarrollo en la ciudad de Sevilla
España del primer sistema para nombrar y
categorizar olas de calor al igual que
lo que ocurren muchos países como
Estados Unidos para rankear a los
huracanes y nombrarlos darle nombre Para
qué sirve esto en el momento que se
nombra a una ola de calor la gente puede
identificarla con Claridad y saber cuál
es su categoría Cuál es su nivel de
severidad y en función de aquello
adoptar las medidas de precaución que
correspondan por otro lado la ciudad
puede también adoptar una serie de
medidas para proteger a la gente por
ejemplo puede establecer puntos de
distribución de agua puede
habilitar salas de emergencia con un
mayor número de personal para atender a
los pacientes que sufran los defectos
del calor extremo pueden habilitar
lugares en la ciudad como centros de
enfriamiento se puede regular el horario
de trabajo de a quienes que aquellos que
elaboran a la intemperie de tal manera
que no lo hagan en las horas de mayor
calor hay una serie de cosas pueden
hacer A través del establecimiento de
este tipo de sistemas para nombrar y
categorizar olas de calor y predecir con
anticipación Cuál será su severidad y
por lo tanto las medidas de protección
adecuadas ese es un ejemplo Sí existen
muchos otros que creo que son
importantes analizar para promover su
réplica en diferentes ciudades del mundo
en ese orden de ideas Verónica Qué
ciudades hay que estén preparadas para
sortear este tipo de situaciones no sé
se me ocurre en este momento por ejemplo
en las ciudades capitales de países en
medio oriente cercanas al Golfo Pérsico
donde están acostumbrados a tener
temperaturas altas y que son ciudades
que se han desarrollado en los últimos
25 o 30 años pueden tener una tecnología
que les pueda hacer mucho más Útil para
enfrentar este tipo de olas de calor
pero que hay por ejemplo de
latinoamérica
Santiago yo creo que a este punto
ninguna ciudad está preparada para estos
climas extremos porque hemos visto
noticias que las ciudades de medio
oriente en cambio están siendo inundadas
por ríos que en pleno desierto no
existían en la India el día de ayer
están arrazándose templos mientras
Europa se quema en la India hay
desbordamiento de ríos Entonces estamos
hablando de que es necesario primero
declarar planes de emergencia climática
haciendo de esto una un instrumento
vinculante de legislaciones que
promuevan la descarbonización urgente
para bajar las emisiones y también que
promuevan planes de contingencia como
las que se acaban de decir pero esos son
planes de contingencia Más allá de eso
tenemos que tener planes de adaptación
lo que se entiende acá es que tenemos
que entender que esto se viene y que
tenemos que saber cómo manejarlo Y cómo
adaptarse soluciones basadas en la
naturaleza es uno de los grandes
ejemplos
áreas naturales
ciudades más verdes promover el tema de
la de los pavimentos mucho más
permeables es decir que tengamos copas
de árboles en toda la ciudad donde
refresque la temperatura hay muchas
soluciones basadas en la naturaleza que
tienen que las ciudades saber y estar
preparadas es necesario tener Esta
preparación pero a través de un
instrumento vinculante que esto le haga
hacer a la ciudad y que no sea nunca más
voluntario porque ahora ya no estamos en
un nivel de querer o no querer hacer
porque esto se viene más fuerte Mauricio
esto como lo dice Verónica pues incluye
no solamente poder colaborarle a la
ciudadanía cuando está en el medio
ola de calor o en una semana o en unos
días de temperaturas muy altas porque
esto también afecta a los cultivos
afecta a los ríos y no solo si hay una
ola de calor también puede haber sequías
prolongadas como por ejemplo la que está
padeciendo el centro de chile desde hace
ya muchísimos meses y afectado
Prácticamente todo el entorno y toda la
vida allí en las ciudades en el campo
cómo Entonces empezar a organizar todo
este montón de aristas que son
necesarias para pensar en una en Cómo
sobrellevar este tipo de situaciones se
piensa Entonces por garantizar seguridad
para los cultivos para poder garantizar
alimento para las personas o mejor
proteger las fuentes hídricas o mejor
proteger a las personas en la ciudad y
que tengan más sombra en los sitios y
que se protejan del sol
todo lo que cada vez mencionar esencial
me compra mi plan entonces absolutamente
Sí yo creo que es fundamental Santiago
entender que la planificación urbana
debe tener como un elemento transversal
la incorporación de criterios de
desarrollo sustentable combate al cambio
climático y construcción de resiliencia
que engloba todo lo que tú acabas de
mencionar Y por supuesto muchas de otras
cosas más en el caso específico para
volver al tema central que nos atañe que
es el del calor extremo hay mucho que se
puede hacer aparte de las medidas de
contingencia que se deben adoptar en
caso de emergencia una ciudad por
ejemplo puede establecer estímulos para
que las construcciones tengan pintura
Blanca reflectiva en el techo solo eso
esa simple solución permite reducir en
tres o cuatro grados centígrados la
temperatura del interior de las
construcciones algo muy sencillo o
promover también techos verdes muros
verdes
complementando lo que decía ver la
pintura reflectiva en los pavimentos
programas de arborización la generación
de nuevos espacios verdes por supuesto
sin duda la promoción de la movilidad
sostenible que genere menos de misiones
porque las divisiones no solamente
contribuyen al cambio climático sino
también calientan más nuestras ciudades
de forma inmediata por lo tanto todo eso
se tiene que tomar en cuenta como una
política pública de planificación urbana
se entienda que este tipo de fenómenos
además de destruir nuestro planeta
atenta contra la vida de las personas de
manera masiva como lo he dicho afectando
a la población más vulnerable Santiago
este amigo un tema de equidad porque el
calor extremo mata particularmente a los
ancianos a las personas de situación de
calle aquellos que trabajan al
intemperie e incluso en algunos países
afecta de manera particularmente severa
a las minorías raciales por lo tanto no
realmente es una amenaza la vida es una
amenaza también a la equidad y a la
economía y a los empleos ese es otro
punto fundamental existe existen
estudios que señalan por ejemplo que en
Estados Unidos en el año 2020 hubo
pérdidas económicas de aproximadamente
100 billones de dólares como resultado
de la reducción en la productividad
laboral causada por el calor extremo Y
eso Por supuesto generó también la
pérdida de miles de empleos claro y hay
que decir también que esto puede generar
olas de desplazamiento de personas que
saldrán de estos sitios tan cálidos o
donde ya las cosechas no pueden ser
sostenibles debido al calor y se moverán
a otras ciudades un poco más altas o
puntos más altos en otros en diferentes
partes de sus propios países o hacia
otros territorios hay países que van a
desaparecer que son territorios
insulares que van a desaparecer
precisamente por el incremento en el
nivel de los mares debido a el
derretimiento de los glaciares ya
veíamos también esta semana Groenlandia
registró 15 grados por encima de grados
positivos en Groenlandia una cifra que
nunca había visto el norte de esta Isla
que pertenece a Dinamarca Mauricio sé
que usted nos acompaña hasta este punto
del programa porque debe salir al
aeropuerto a tomar un vuelo y agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros haber
sacado el espacio para acompañarnos y a
ver expuesto estos puntos importantes
espero tenerlo con nosotros en una
próxima oportunidad de un gusto haber
conversado con usted y sigo conversando
entonces con Verónica sobre este tema
Muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos
Muchas gracias Santiago un saludo
especial a usted y a Verónica
Verónica pues entonces conversamos usted
y yo seguimos haciendo análisis de este
tema y quería preguntarle Entonces por
las políticas que balance puede hacer
uno de la región de América Latina en
cuanto a políticas para hacer frente a
todos esta cantidad de temas
medioambientales que hay la
deforestación los daños de las cuencas
hídricas también la sobreexplotación de
la tierra con cultivos y ese movimiento
de la frontera agrícola que sucede o es
una de las grandes críticas que hay por
lo menos para la administración actual
en un país Como por ejemplo Brasil Cómo
evaluó usted las políticas de los
diferentes países en la actualidad
Cuáles van en cierta forma un poco
adelantados en estas políticas
medioambientales
bueno Santiago creo que nos falta mucho
es a la región de América Latina
específicamente es una de las regiones
con mayor biodiversidad en el mundo pero
una de las que también son de las más
amenazadas o vulnerables frente al
Cambio Climático Esto significa que es
una región que está perdiendo mucho de
su entorno natural Brasil por ejemplo
tiene una pérdida acordémonos el año
anterior y hace dos años que se quemó
parte de Gran Chaco igual que igual que
el gran parte de del Gran Chaco de
Bolivia y esto se debe justamente a
políticas que incentivan la expansión
agrícola y por tanto la tala y la
deforestación de toda ese pulmón verde
que es de del planeta entero Creo que
todavía nos falta tener un entendimiento
muy fuerte entre la entre la y la
coordinación que debe existir dentro lo
urbano y lo rural entendiendo que las
ciudades sean urbanizado y que para el
2050 el 70% de las de los habitantes van
a estar en las ciudades pero también van
a depender de la parte rural que
lamentablemente está siendo afectada no
solamente por el cambio climático como
tú mencionabas y que eso produce una
migración sino que también debido a los
calores extremos o inundaciones esos
esas áreas Rurales se están perdiendo y
perdiendo mano de obra Entonces eso va a
tener que ver mucho con la seguridad
alimentaria todo esto significa
Santiago que nosotros como como región
latinoamericana deberíamos tener muy
claro el tema de hacia una transición
ecológica o una transición energética A
qué vamos Porque
la única solución y creo que la solución
nos da va a dar la misma naturaleza Es
que los combustibles fósiles simplemente
van a tener que dejar de existir Y qué
vamos a hacer cuando no tengamos toda
esa energía contaminante pero al fin y
al cabo esa energía A qué nos vamos a
abocar cómo nos vamos a enfrentar y qué
es y cuáles son las alternativas
Entonces si nosotros no tenemos claro
como región Y cómo país y como ciudad
con Qué planes a largo plazo y mediano
plazo vamos a hacer esa transformación y
y de cuáles energías vamos a depender
Entonces vamos vamos a estar en una
desventaja competitiva frente al resto
del mundo no estamos hablando entonces Y
te digo por por señalar la mayoría de
ciudades en la región de las 35 ciudades
muy pocas muy pocas contadas con los
dedos de la mano tienen planes de acción
climática y de riesgos esto es
imprescindible todavía las ciudades no
cuentan ni con eso y son las primeras
que van a tener justamente que lidiar
así como y lo hicieron en la pandemia
precisamente con temas de riesgos como
los que estamos hablando Verónica
Siempre se exige mucho y se presiona
mucho a las administraciones de las
ciudades a los gobiernos nacionales a
implementar este tipo de de políticas o
por lo menos tener una agenda ambiental
que sea un poco más prioritaria no
solamente agendas económicas que sabemos
que el tema económico pesa mucho en los
países de América Latina debido a la
desigualdad y a la Pobreza pero por
ejemplo el presidente de Estados Unidos
Joe biden anunció esta semana una serie
de medidas muchos dijeron que son
bastante modestas precisamente para
combatir el cambio climático pero nunca
decretó ningún tipo de emergencia
climática que eso podría promover el uso
de más recursos o por lo menos mover el
congreso de forma
para tomar decisiones
qué tanto están haciendo los gobiernos a
nivel de América Latina y Qué tanto está
comprometida a la sociedad porque la
exigimos mucho a los políticos pero es
que nosotros también somos los que
contaminamos nosotros somos los que
usamos el gas la electricidad para los
seres acondicionados y usamos los
automóviles los aviones los trenes las
motos y contaminamos y contaminamos los
ríos qué tan comprometidos estamos
a ver primera cosa con la relación a
Estados Unidos creo que desde el año
pasado de la cop 27 de la 26 dejó mucho
que desean el complemento el compromiso
por demás tibio de los Estados Unidos y
ahora con la con la sentencia de la
Corte Suprema nos deja aún más en en
vilo porque impide que las políticas que
se comprometió el presidente biden se
vayan a aplicar Especialmente con la
agencia de regulación
Epa no sobre más de 18 estados que
revelaron a que se siga con el uso del
Carbón eso significa que no van a poder
cumplir con aquellas metas que que que
pretendió Estados Unidos eso por un lado
la segunda es justamente que los
gobiernos Pues de la región
si como te mencionaba América Latina no
es de las regiones más contaminantes sin
embargo creo que en el principio de
economías y de responsabilidades de
diferenciadas comunes pero diferenciadas
todos los países se han comprometido a
bajar sus emisiones no obstante eso como
tú bien dices no significa que es una
responsabilidad solamente de los
gobiernos es definitivamente de la
comunidad y de la sociedad civil y de
todos los habitantes de este gran
planeta y de nuestra casa común yo no
veo todavía que hay un cambio sustancial
en el modelo de consumo el modelo de
consumo Es lo que nos está llevando
justamente a lo que tenemos hoy Por qué
Porque nos hemos acostumbrado
simplemente a abrirle el Grifo y que nos
salga el agua a aprender un switch Y
dejarla ir prendido la televisión o los
aparatos electrónicos es decir el
Confort al que ha llegado el ser humano
de hoy de este siglo es un estilo de
vida no sostenible De hecho este 28 se
está lanzando el día del sobregiro del
planeta que ya llegamos a un sobregiro
así como tenemos en el banco sobre giros
estamos ya sobregirados por el sobreuso
justamente de los recursos naturales por
el por el estilo de vida y el consumo
que lo estamos haciendo que es un tema
que le hemos hecho esta que le hemos
hecho seguimiento en este programa año
año hacemos evaluación de ese informe
sobre el sobregiro que básicamente
llevamos ya muchos años gastándonos los
recursos antes del año de uso y cada año
El el consumo aumenta usted habla del
estilo de vida de este Confort en el que
estamos Verónica estas olas de calor
este clima extremo que estamos viendo
estas inundaciones cada vez más fuertes
Los Huracanes más fuertes las Nevadas
más constantes inviernos más cortos
veranos más largos va a cambiar nuestro
estilo de vida como sociedad como
planeta estamos en un punto de quiebre
vamos a cambiar nuestra forma de vida
para los próximos años
creo que como seres humanos y aquí te
respondo como como ser humano creo que
nos va a aprender a nos va a tocar
aprender a golpes Fíjate que estaba
leyendo alguna información sobre Europa
y ya hay preocupación de lo que se
avecina por el corte de
energía de gas esto por el por la guerra
verdad y tocará justamente
no usar mayores recursos como el agua no
habrá como
mucho tiempo la calefacción etcétera Y
eso es un poco lo que nos toca no
aprender a vivir con menos recursos y no
esperar a que venga una guerra a que
venga una ola de calor a Que las
temperaturas este pues suban cuando
podríamos ya incorporar ese hábito como
anteriormente Y hace algunas décadas y
hace algunos años teníamos de una forma
más sostenible de vivir y es son cosas
tan simples como la del día a día de la
forma de movilizarse de respetar el uso
del agua respetar la vida Silvestre
mantener
espacios verdes en las ciudades es decir
cosas tan básicas no usar el plástico es
decir cosas tan básicas como esas que te
juro que uniendo todos esos granitos de
arena haríamos un efecto desde la
sociedad civil mucho más allá y más
importante de los propios gobiernos
Usted cree que este invierno para Europa
con estas condiciones que se están
empezando a mezclar por esa posible
falta de suministro de gas que viene de
Rusia por el tema del conflicto también
esta falta de distribución de los granos
y cereales de Ucrania que está llevando
al planeta prácticamente al borde de una
hambruna y está causando muchos
problemas en varios países de Asia y de
África puede ser ese punto de quiebre
entonces que necesitemos para
dimensionar un poco Cómo puede llegar a
ser nuestra vida si agotamos los
recursos si excedemos el uso de recursos
Como por ejemplo la energía y no
buscamos formas de de Buscar energías
renovables o energías más limpias que
sean más sustentables y no depender
necesariamente de otras fuentes de
energía
si Santiago creo que estamos en un
momento tan crítico y tan globalizado
que cualquier cosa que hagamos en un
lado va a afectar al otro Fíjate que
Europa ha sido uno de los que más se ha
comprometido en relación al tema del
acuerdo de París y del cambio climático
y está haciendo el más afectado por el
tema de las olas de calor y la gran
amenaza que significa el cambio
climático la India estamos viendo que se
desbordan los ríos por donde quiera y el
medio oriente en el desierto donde todo
era seco vemos se desbordan Ríos
imagínate y en América Latina pues no se
diga en Estados Unidos y en el cono Sur
es decir un poco La telaraña se está
moviendo por todo lado no Entonces
esto
exacerbado por una guerra y exacerbado
por una hambruna sin duda alguna se
vienen dan años es muy difíciles al que
tenemos que estar preparados no quiero
ser mal Agüero pero yo creo que es
momento de decir las cosas como son y
las cosas reales Cómo se vienen porque
de otra forma no lo vamos a entender no
queremos entender no quedemos queremos
dejar nuestro Confort y si y y
normalmente pensar que eso no nos pasa
aquí y ahora sino que es algo más allá
que está pasando en otro lado del
Planeta y no es así estamos viendo como
cada vez más las cosas están tan
vinculadas tan globalizadas que está
afectando al resto del mundo creo que se
conjuga También acá esta necesidad de
Confort de vivir bien también cierta
forma el egoísmo de las sociedades nos
falta sin duda mucho como sociedad para
aprender a convivir aquí en conjunto y
entender que estamos acá en este planeta
y que no podemos abusar de los recursos
que tenemos y que debemos compartir y
que debemos ser un poco cautelosos en el
que le damos somos una generación que
sin duda alguna va a dejar un paso
bastante crítico por nuestro planeta
Verónica me quedan ya pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa segundos ya su
conclusión que sigue entonces para la
humanidad con este cambio climático que
cada vez es más rápido con el calor que
se nos está poniendo ya como uno de los
enemigos para garantizar nuestra
subsistencia En este planeta
Santiago alguien decía uno de los
grandes presidentes de Estados Unidos
decía
Esta es la generación que por primera
vez va a ver los defectos del cambio
climático y la Última Generación que va
a poder hacer algo por el tema de cambio
climático Yo pienso que es ahora no es
el futuro es hoy hoy tenemos que hacer
porque ya estamos sintiendo los defectos
del cambio climático y tenemos que
hablarlo y elevar las voces en todo lado
y los medios de comunicación Gracias son
unos grandes aliados para esto pues
muchas gracias Verónica Arias en la
ciudad de Quito Muchas gracias por
habernos acompañado en el programa
recuerda el compromiso no es solamente
los gobiernos es de nosotros es suyo
también todos tenemos que colaborar
sigan con la programación de France 24
[Música]